what's in here what does it do and can I
make it from scratch it's the stuff
inside your stuff ingredients for the
purposes of peanut butter
peanuts are just peanut oil and then all
the stuff in here that is not peanut oil
so things like sugars starches and
proteins so when you blend a bunch of
peanuts what you end up with is peanut
particles floating around in peanut oil
now this is called a suspension because
the peanut particles are suspended in
the oil eventually those particles they
will settle to the bottom leaving you
with peanut oil floating on top and no
matter how long you keep your blender
going your peanut butter is gonna
separate out into two layers and it's
also gonna be running because at 25
degrees Celsius a suspension of 50 to
60% peanut particles in peanut oil which
is what peanut butter is is just runny
[Music]
but this peanut butter does not separate
and it's not running so what's in here
that's not in here that makes for such a
huge difference in texture well this
just has peanuts and salt we knew that
and this has peanuts in salt too but
there's a bunch of other stuff in here
first on that list is sugar and that's
in there mostly for flavor
there's also 2% or less of molasses
which I'm guessing is more for color
than for flavor
then there's fully hydrogenated
vegetable oils in this case rapeseed aka
canola and soybean oils and mono and
diglycerides now let's talk about the
hydrogenated oils first to make a very
long story short hydrogenating veggie
oils changes them from unsaturated fats
which are usually liquid at room
temperature to saturated fats which are
usually solid at room temperature now
I'll post a link to a video in the
description that explains why this is
the case more fully but all you need to
worry about right now is liquid to solid
so adding hydrogenated veggies which
remember solid to peanut butter is I
think what keeps it from being runny but
there's still the issue of separation
and that I think is where the mono and
diglycerides come in now these molecules
are kind of like a third of a fad or 2/3
of a fad respectfully they're sort of
fatty on this end here and kind of
watery on this end here and for that
reason they're used to mix fatty stuff
like peanut oil with watery stuff like
peanut sugars and protein keeping it all
together so to make our non runny non
separating peanut butter we're going to
need direct from nature versions of both
hydrogenated veggie aisles and mono and
diglycerides now chemically hydrogenated
veggie oil were pretty close to butter
but out of respect for vegetarians
vegans and those among us who are
lactose intolerant I'm going to use
cocoa butter which comes from plants and
is really high in saturated fat and as
you can see it is solid at room
temperature and instead of mono and
diglycerides I'm going to use lecithin
in this case soy lecithin which comes
from soybeans and is a natural
emulsifier so let's do this and see what
happens
[Music]
we're getting there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so let's see good sign not runny
not very runny at least come on come on
you can do it
this looks unfortunate I hope it tastes
better than it looks
come on there may be a better way to do
this your hangar ah it's getting
everywhere okay good enough so now
obviously I'm not gonna be able to tell
you whether this is gonna separate until
it sits around for a while so I'm gonna
clean this up and then let it sit around
for a while but I can taste it and tell
you what it tastes like
because cocoa butter has a very distinct
aroma actually if you add something to
hot chocolate it's incredible but let's
let's see what this tastes like hmm very
um sticks to everything
it's sticky but you don't really taste
it nearly like peanut butter it tastes
pretty good okay so um I'm gonna go put
this somewhere and I'll let you know
what happens all right so it's been a
few months and I have our homemade
peanut butter now as you can see it has
separated so you might think we failed
but back when I made this I also made
this this just has peanuts and salt no
cocoa butter no soy lecithin and if you
do a little bit of math you'll see that
our version separates a little bit less
which is great but what about the
running this issue let's find out
so here we go moment of truth
okay so it's still running but that is
way less than the peanut butter with
just peanuts that is not bad so overall
our homemade peanut butter separates but
not as much and it still runs but also
not as much I am reasonably impressed
that's not bad I'm gonna give this seven
out of ten solid but not perfect now if
you guys have comments let me know below
and if you an idea for an episode hit me
up on Twitter until then I'm gonna go
eat this sort of runny sort of separated
peanut butter
[Music]